we're here at the American Music Awards
with the most talented musicians you've
ever seen just kidding first of all we
need to talk about the fashion Mecca can
you please narrate what's happening with
your boys today um well they it's a
Matthew McConaughey yeah fashion
expresses Who I am
but tonight I'm feeling Western I just
wanted Ben to be comfortable I know he's
a big advocate for bullet eyes and I
couldn't leave him hanging
what is happening with Colton you guys
don't like him we saw you at iHeartRadio
that is not true
we love Colton as a person Dean as
famous are saying Colton is not his
bachelor and I'm saying it's gonna
disrupt him pretty bad this could be a
what did we cut you spend the weekend
with Jason and Blake you realize how
creative guys they are it's hard not to
be team Jason or Blake you know why was
ABC not team Jason or Blake what do they
have in their past
are they not fun do they not are they
not sexy sexy I have no idea what's the
reason I mean I I think Colton is gonna
be like we're gonna see his whole story
play out through this show we're gonna
see failures successes hopefully the end
he's down on one knee and he's in love
but with cold we're getting like the raw
view of it I think Jason player kind of
prepped to be the bachelor you think
it's because he was a virgin I would
know what else is going on how are your
personal dating lives dating you had
lots of DM the training wheels are still
on it still learning how to do it you
know I don't believe that for a second
you are so full of it now that People's
Choice nominated podcast but help I suck
at dating if you haven't subscribed yet
you should I'll be sure to check it out
like yeah I was on The Bachelor now I'm
getting DMS like crazy podcast you would
have more viewers if you listened to the
podcast we talked a lot about that
your dating life it's few and far
between
I say I think Dean and I are both still
learning we struggle it's bad don't go
on a date with us it gets really awkward
too fast you don't let's talk about
[Music]